Anne: I'm in MOMA's storage with
Henri Matisse's blue window.
Matisse had first made a name for himself
as a painter of these
brilliantly colored canvases
with very discrete
structuring brush strokes.
In this work of 1913 you see
him at a different moment.
The mood, the overall color
palette is more subdued,
and there is a clear
sense of Matisse engaging
with the Cubist geometries of
his contemporaries of the moment.
Matisse's overarching goals at
this moment remained constant
to arrive somehow at the
essential character of things.
This is, in fact, a very
reduced version of the view
of his studio that he saw
out of his bedroom window.
When you first look at
it the overall impression
is of this expanse of blue, of this
virtually monochromatic canvas.
Several scholars believe
that in creating this picture
Matisse used what was known as
a Claude, or a black mirror.
In fact, this little square in the
lower right of the composition may be
a stylized representation
of this artist's tool.
They were a device that eliminates
all sensations of color,
probably a very useful tool
for him in stylizing, reducing,
simplifying what he saw before him.
When you look at this work
with x-rays for example,
you can see that up in the tree areas
he gradually eliminated details.
The more you look at it and begin to look
at the relations of one part to another
you realize that a major
reason for its beauty
is that Matisse has so carefully aligned
virtually every element in this picture.
Everything in some way lines up.
The top of the statue with
this black line of the window
or the top of the lamp, or this
band that may have been a curtain
may be a wall, but that Matisse
extends down into what really becomes
this wonderful abstract blue stripe.